you know I've spent last the last couple
months a lot of the last couple months
trying to decide whether I'm a [ __ ] or
not I'll tell you why because okay so I
have an old-school father anybody have
like an old-school father who's yeah
right you're always talking about your
generation in your book and [ __ ] your
gender right right
so I was like okay I'm sorry I started
to take stock and what it means to be a
man in 2017
I can build some [ __ ] I can fix some
[ __ ] so I figure for 2017 for my dad
that puts me over the fiftieth
percentile at least right and then now
look guys I watch movies on the plane
because I travel so much so I always and
I'm Way behind
so I finally saw a movie called the
redness round of applause people have
seen the retina okay all right so ah not
a lot of ps5 so for those of you don't
know by the way not a great movie to
watch if you're trying to decide if
you're a [ __ ] by the way not so I'm
watching it and guys it's set in the
frontier Leonardo DiCaprio there's
avenging the death of his son and he
goes through some [ __ ] right I mean he
could [ __ ] by a bear that's not great
right but I'm looking at the movie as a
man trying to decide if I could do what
he did I'm like oh yeah I could build a
fire right now do that all I can do some
hot and I know how to do that and then
there was one scene that made me feel
like such a [ __ ] there's that scene
where he's eating that live bison heart
do you remember that he's eating a live
bison heart like it's the best thing
he's ever had in his life he's just
eating it down
blood dripping off his beard but he's
eating it like it's the best thing he's
ever tasted guys if my bananas too mushy
I'm like
[Music]
this dude ain't alive animal there's a
breathless spot on my banana my [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
[Music]
and then on top of that it's over the
last couple months I've been I had this
conversation with my wife almost every
day I'm like why do you wear yoga pants
every day every day and she said they're
so comfortable and I said how
comfortable can they be she said you
just got to try them on I'm gonna tell
you something right now in your dick
looks [ __ ] huge in those things I
could I thought I told my wife I'm like
my dick always looks like this she goes
I've never seen her look like that
before and it's soft they're so soft
you've been hiding them from us that's
what I thought unicorn hair would feel
like you know to me like that kind of
soft and they lift and they separate
they support in all the right places
guys I [ __ ] dare any dude in here put
him on walk 50 feet and not get a
hard-on I [ __ ] dare you it was like a
little cotton-blend [ __ ] across my
living room
I came three times before that Bauhaus
[Music]
you